PFIZER'S VACCINE HAS PROVEN
EFFECTIVE AGAINST THE UK AND
SOUTH AFRICA VARIANTS.
>> WHILE THE TRENDS ARE POSITIVE
IN THE U.S., HALFWAY AROUND THE
WORLD THERE ARE TERRIBLE -- WE
DO MEAN TERRIBLE SCENES IN
INDIA.
WE ARE SEEING RECORD NEW CASES
THERE, AND THE VIRUS IS NOW
SPREADING FASTER THAN ANYPLACE
ELSE IN THE WORLD.
CHRIS LIVESAY VISITED A HOSPITAL
IN NEW DELHI.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
AS THE COVID SURGE CONTINUES TO
KILL INDIANS IN RECORD NUMBERS,
HOSPITALS LIKE THIS ONE ARE
STRUGGLING DESPERATELY JUST TO
HAVE ENOUGH BEDS.
AS WE'RE WITNESSING, ARE HAVING
TO TURN THE SICK AWAY.
SHORT OF BREATH, DESPERATE FOR
OXYGEN AND A BED, BUT HERE AT
THE PRIVATE HOSPITAL WITH SOME
OF THE BEST RESOURCES IN NEW
DELHI, THERE ARE NONE LEFT.
SO THEY SEND HER AWAY.
DR. NABIL RAHMAD RUNS THIS
EMERGENCY ROOM CONVERTED INTO
EXTRA SPACE FOR AN ICU,
ABSOLUTELY CRUSHED WITH
PATIENTS.
HE SAID THEY RESORTED TO
PURCHASING THEIR OWN OXYGEN
PRIVATELY AT EXORBITANTLY HIGH
PRICES AMID A SHORTAGE
NATIONWIDE.
>> PATIENTS COME TO HOSPITAL
BECAUSE THEY'RE SERIOUSLY SICK.
THEY NEED VENTILATOR SUPPORT.
>> Reporter: THESE PATIENTS ARE
EXTREMELY SICK, BUT ALSO
EXTREMELY LUCKY.
LUCKY TO HAVE OXYGEN.
LUCKY TO HAVE ACCESS TO DOCTORS.
LUCKY JUST TO HAVE A BED IN A
HOSPITAL THAT'S ALREADY OVER
CAPACITY, AND IN A COUNTRY
THAT'S DESPERATELY WAGING A WAR
AND LOSING TO COVID-19.
MANY OF INDIA'S VICTIMS GOT
INFECTED DURING RECENT MASS
RELIGIOUS GATHERINGS PROMOTED BY
THE HINDU NATIONALIST PARTY OF
PRIME MINISTER MODI AS IT
CAMPAIGNED IN RECENT STATE
ELECTIONS.
SCHOOL TEACHERS ORDERED TO
OVERSEE VOTING STATIONS WERE
AMONG THE BIGGEST VICTIMS.
SOME 700 DIED OF COVID.
ONE IS THE MOTHER OF SAN YSIDRO
-- OF SHAD HASAN, NOW ON LIFE
SUPPORT.
SHE SAYS SHE'LL NEVER FORGET THE
GOVERNMENT FOR PUTTING HER LIFE
AT RISK.
>> AT THIS TIME OF CRISIS, HOW
CAN YOU BE SO STUPID?
>> Reporter: FOR MOST INDIANS,
IT'S EVEN MORE DIRE.
SOME DYING IN LINE AS THEY PLEAD
FOR OXYGEN.
A HOSPITAL BED OR EVEN JUST A
PLACE TO BE LAID TO REST.
KEEP IN MIND, INDIA'S MASSIVE
POPULATION OF 1.4 BILLION
PEOPLE.
WITH MANY CASES AND DEATHS GOING
UNREPORTED, THE REAL NUMBERS ARE
FEARED TO BE AS MUCH AS TEN
TIMES HIGHER WITH CASES NOW
SPREADING ALL ACROSS SOUTHER